the arches to welcome tourists to
downtown las vegas will be lit up
tonight
the 80-foot tall archway is the newest
addition to
our skyline bianca holman is there live
for us with a look hey bianca it looks
beautiful
tonight these arches will be illuminated
by the city of las vegas
they span across las vegas boulevard
between st louis and bob stupak avenues
right here at the base of the strat
hotel these arches welcome tourists and
locals to historic downtown las vegas
the blue arches feature a pink retro
inspired las vegas emblem that is
suspended above the street
these arches were designed by perkins
designed and installed by yesco
yes go is a company that's celebrating
100 years right here in the valley
they've become synonymous with our
town's most iconic signs
i really think everyone's going to want
to go down and and stand beneath it and
take
take a picture and just sit back and and
think about the wonderful history of
this
amazing community that we've got and
like i say we couldn't be more honored
and more proud to be involved with this
project
and a major amazing site indeed and here
are some fun facts about the arches
one leg weighs more than 18 thousand
pounds
and the there are thirteen thousand
lights across the arches
after tonight's event the gateway arches
will always be illuminated at
dusk and then be illuminated throughout
the night reporting here in downtown las
vegas bianca holman 8 news now
how exciting all right bianca thank you